so
you were to have read
today the section on
classification is just a small section
right on categorization and then the
next section on cost basically on the
enuma elish the mesopotamian creation
myth
okay now that's the most fun that's the
most archaic of creationists that we
have in written form
in anything approaching a state of
completeness
and so it's interesting from the
historical perspective
because it's so archaic
it's also an ex like the mesopotamians
had an extraordinarily well developed
dogma religious dogma as far as i've
been able to determine in some ways
well
well i think in many ways
jewish and christian theology are
elaborations on a mesopotamian theme now
iliad it points out that the
mesopotamian creation myth although it's
about 5 000 years and it's old in its
extent form
is definitely based on oral traditions
that are much older than that so it's
not it's not like you can say that the
sumerians just
originated the enuma elish in a very
brief period of time on ground that
hadn't been prepared they just codified
traditions that have been handed down
orally to that date so we haven't been
written form
now
the first thing i wanted to tell you
about was this notion of categorization
and
i think
i think this is
roger brown pointed out 20 years ago
where there abouts that
we have always in psychology tended to
think that the way that people think is
the way that scientists think and the
way that we categorize things
is in terms of the categories that we
think are appropriate from the
scientific or the logical perspective
brown points out that this is well that
is that a minimal amount of
investigation basically in the
psycholinguistic domain immediately
indicated that this was in fact false
and that we do not categorize things
naturally the way that people do
scientifically in other words we don't
use the notion of the proper set and he
uses as a standard example of the proper
set the idea of triangles and
you can tell what a triangle is
absolutely you can define what's a
triangle what isn't there's no fuzziness
about the borders and everything either
fits in the set or is outside of the set
and by contrast our natural categories
don't seem to be of that type they have
fuzzy boundaries and they're more
concerned with function so to speak or
with affective relevance than with
sensory
and with with
uh
absolutely determinable sensory essence
so
we categorize in much more vague manner
and it seems to me that it's i give you
a listing in this in this document of
the qualities of natural categorization
as they've been described by george
lachoff in his book women fire and
dangerous things and black ops is
basically following up on a tradition
that is i'm not a psycholinguist and
this is all new news to me basically but
black ops is being following up on a
tradition that was established by roger
brown and eleanor rosch who is one of
his students and
eleanor rosh has made a big name for
herself studying categorization the
thing i think so interesting about this
is that
what rosh
and lachof describe as categories are
very very much like the kinds of
categories that religious thinkers have
used that have been studied from a
completely different perspective by
people like jung and mercia eliade
so it's not that surprising if you think
about it because it's obvious that
religious categories aren't
proper sets they're natural categories
arcane people
think in religious categories and have
always thought that way so
it's not like it's not that surprising
what's surprisingly i guess more
surprising is that
the overlap between the two literatures
is is not well explored or nowhere
so uh
the first thing we should do i guess is
think of to think about this notion of
categorization
yeah okay lackhof describes natural
categories as cognitive models the first
thing he says is that they are embodied
with regards to their content which
essentially means that they can be used
without necessarily being defined
means that they are implicit in action
without necessarily being implicit in
description
so
basically what lackhoff is pointing out
is that
if you act towards
a number of different things as if they
are the same thing
with regards to your actions then you
are in fact
uh you are in fact treating those
objects as if they're in the same
category because one domain of category
can be fun like significance for motor
output and that's you think if you think
about it's like what defines chair
that because chairs vary in all sorts of
ways they vary so much that there's very
there may be very little sensory
overlap between one chair and another
there's not much
there's not much similar between a stump
for example and the kind of designer
chair that you might see in a museum
they're very different objects but the
thing they have in common is their
implication for output which is the
chairs or things that you can sit on
right they're defined by their by their
significance not by their sensory nature
so
i used an example here
what makes a dog you you might say i
can't say but i know one when i see one
which is another indication that you'd
be using a natural category
dog is something friendly something to
be petted and something to play with
although such knowledge does not
comprise everything that makes up what
you regard as dog the thing that's
interesting about those ideas something
friendly something to be petted and
something to play with is that
in a sense those are not precisely the
attributes of the dog think of the
natural category of dog because what
you're if you define a dog as a friend
or as something to play with you're
actually defining the object in terms of
your interactions with it and not in
terms of the object
and a lot of the terms we use have
exactly that nature like beautiful for
example
it says when you define it say if you
define another person as beautiful it's
very difficult to tell exactly where it
is that that quality
resides many people say beauty is in the
eye of the beholder we know there's
quite a substantial amount of cultural
variation
in terms of attitudes towards beauty so
it's very difficult to pin down what
constitutes beauty from the objective
perspective i mean there's been a
certain
certain attempts to do that and they've
been somewhat successful
but the point is is that
as beauty is in the eye of a beholder
but it's something that we naturally
attribute to an object so a lot of the
things that we consider properties of
objects are actually what lachoff
describes as interactional properties
they're things that we attribute to the
thing that actually arise as a
consequence of our interaction with the
thing
so like the notion of friend
when you when you describe if you put
someone in the category a friend you're
actually describing them in terms of
your pattern of interactions with them
although you attribute the qualities
that make up those interactions to them
and you do that automatically and what
i'm suggesting with with regards to this
study of categorization is that
we do that that is the natural way that
we think as we think about things in
terms of their implication for our
behavioral output
and we need to do that because that's
what adaptation means if you've adapted
to something you've structured your
behavior well basically what you've done
is structure your behavior in the
presence of that thing so that it does
what you want it to do which means
basically that it doesn't threaten you
that it doesn't hurt you
that it furthers your progress towards a
goal or that it constitutes that goal
itself that's behavioral adaptation
and
well
those things the things that make up
that category of objects to which you've
structured behavioral adaptation that's
explored territory that's the domain of
the known say in that domain is
everything that you understand how to
act towards now what i'm trying to
suggest in the course of this whole
manuscript is that's how your brain
works
the scientific overlay of scientific
categorizations is just a thin veneer on
top of that and in some sense it's an
irrelevant veneer from the perspective
of emotional regulation science has
enabled us to describe things ever more
accurately so that we can keep track of
them but still what we're interested in
is determining how to behave in the
presence of things that's what we want
to know
okay now
lachoff points out a few other things
about natural categories and i want you
to think about this in regards to the
sorts of categories that we're going to
talk about for the remainder of course
he says they're characterized by basic
level categorization of basic level
primacy and basically what he means by
that is that we tend to view things as
in a category or as objects themselves
if they're the right size for us in
other words that the world that we
perceive which is the world of
experience
which is in some sense the only world
you can get access to is human sized
the cat there are categories that
naturally spring to mind because they're
handy that's a good way of thinking much
like the english imperial system of
measurement
we can we define things in terms of the
english imperial system and it's very
handy literally a foot is a foot long an
inch is the length of one digit i mean
the point lakh is trying to make is that
the world of experience presents itself
the way it presents itself because of
the interaction between our physiology
and whatever it is that's out there now
one of the things we're going to try to
explore is what does it mean to say
whatever it is
that's out there i mean we tend to think
of it scientifically as the objective
world which would be exactly the same as
it is now if none of us were here except
that none of us would be here the point
lackhoff is trying to make is that what
we define as reality is somewhat more or
what we experience is reality is more
complex than that it's an interaction
between whatever it is that's out there
and us and everything that we think of
is real we define in like in terms of
our experience of temporal duration and
size and weight and
i guess the only way
the only way you can get your mind
around this to some degree is to try to
think of
what lackhoff is saying in a sense is
that the fact that we're human and have
the characteristics that we have which
are basically our limitations means that
the universe
is constituted in a particular way with
regards to us is that we have a built-in
level of analysis
it's obviously not the subatomic level
or the molecular level it's not the
cosmic level either it's human-sized
now if you start thinking about what
would constitute reality in the absence
of a human observer the first problem
that you run into is the problem of a
reference point is
you no longer have anything against
which to judge things like duration or
size and certainly not things like
certainly not things like color or
beauty or emotional significance
those categories obviously disappear
what happens to the sensor categories is
not all that easy to figure out either
so i can't i already can't figure it out
in the
um
richard feynman in his book the
character of physical law
just discusses
encoding the nature of human experience
in a mathematical form and sending it to
uh
alien so that he could reconstruct the
world that we experience
based on the
proportion of an elemental character or
an element like an atom or something
like that
and he gives a fairly good
just from that it's
convincing that you could describe the
world independent of human experience if
you define if if you define the
parameters that
that make up our capacity to experience
is that if you if you you can just you
could possibly describe
the world that we
the world in terms of
something which is transhuman
by by using mathematical symbols well
that's interesting so feignman says but
that he he would define our level of
analysis mathematically as well as what
it is that we're experiencing and that
would give an alien the capacity to see
what it is that we see he wasn't he
wasn't talking about he was talking
about
a transhuman
reality
fireman doesn't uh
subject the reality of reality to the
presence of the subject right right well
but nonetheless that alien is a subject
i mean
and must have
some sort of intelligence that is at
least in some vague way like our own in
order to
interpret what we send out there so he's
really not
he's not
so there's an alien out there who has a
similar enough intelligence to ours that
can ins that can understand this thing
that we've sent out i mean then then
they're the subject in question well it
opens up
it
draws question to
i mean it's sort of it's a question to
mark over the possibility of
saying that reality is
dependent on that it's irrelevant it's
ridiculous to talk about reality in the
absence of a human subject
well transhuman yes but trans subject no
okay what's the difference between
richard
okay well i don't want to make too much
of this because it isn't like
it's not something that's like that's
critical to the arguments that we're
gonna we're gonna undertake one of the
things i want to tell you about is how
mythological categories represent the
category of all things that exist in the
absence of a subject which is kind of a
strange category and even the
mythological like in the scientific
world we presume an objective
independent reality i don't want to
argue i certainly don't want to argue
about that because it's way too
complicated an issue but myth also
presumes that something exists in the
absence of a perceiver
or in the absence of a subject although
the thing that exists is very difficult
to define and that's one of the things
we're going to take a brief look at
today because
my question is what is what does science
have to do it at all with that
science
of the size the size of the
of the reference point and that which
presents us up to the reference well all
that lackhoff is basically saying is
that certain categories seem to present
themselves to us more naturally than
others like the category cat presents
itself to us more naturally than the
category of species of cat because we
naturally were naturally predisposed so
to speak towards
making an object out of
out of something like a cat now no one
knows exactly why it is that certain
forms of categorization appear to us
more naturally than other sorts i
suspect it has something to do with what
you can say but it has something to do
with our biological hard wiring which is
not really much of an answer just the
way we are we perceive certain things
more accurately than we perceive other
things i mean
just to take a trivial example
in this room
we'll focus all of our attention on each
other's faces like i'm not going to
spend a lot of time when i'm talking to
you looking at your hands my natural
point of orientation in our discussion
is your face it's very significant for
me and i think you see this sort of
thing if you look at children's drawings
i mean your child's drawing of a person
is you know usually something like this
maybe there's not even a body but
the head is 90 of the person and the
face is 90 of the head and that's i
think this is a proto-linguistic
representation of it of a human being
children tend to produce these sorts of
figures spontaneously i would say that's
kind of a natural hieroglyphic that
stands for person
and the things that are most relevant
about the person or the things that are
focused in on by the child it's just
certain things appear to us more
naturally than other things and those
things more naturally constitute our
world
so
we're talking about size really quickly
you return to physics and what's
intuitive
you can sort of look at the you can sort
of divide the universe into three very
basic levels of orders of magnitude you
can have sort of what's intuitive is the
newtonian universe we all live in and
you can have the cosmic order which is
sort of defined by isinium mechanics and
space time and you can go to quantum
mechanics which is smaller than you
could possibly perceive and if you if
you look at the mathematics involved in
each one the newtonian equations the
ones that make sense to you that you
think in and the other ones seem like
when you read about the first time you
think to yourself how could this be but
in a in a sort of mathematical sense
they're all true that's an excellent
example
because the new that's an excellent
example because the newtonian universe
is intuitive and the reason that it's
intuitive from the lachaffia perspective
is that the laws are in accordance with
our motor patterns our patterns of
adaptation i mean piaget's pointed out
that we first adapt to objects from the
motor perspective as a consequence of
exploration then we build our abstract
notions about our relationships with
those objects as a consequence of our
established motor patterns and that
basically that basically sums up the
notion of embodied knowledge and your
point is that
these other universes are
counter-intuitive they're not in
accordance with our experience well
that's partly because they aren't the
they aren't the left
the levels of resolution or the orders
of magnitude towards which we actually
adapt our behavior
so
yeah
okay
anyways you can finish reading through
the the
the properties of natural categories
they have interesting categories i also
think that
well
membership and centrality gradients is
kind of an interesting category
as is familial resemblance the idea of
familial resemblance is quite
interesting and basically what the mrs
roche's big contributor the thing that
she's worked on
say that
we have notions of prototypes for our
categories is that there's a it's kind
of an ideal thing that constitutes the
category like the category bird people
would say for example that a robin is a
more prototypical bird than an ostrich
and you can't exactly sorry do you have
a question yeah
well maybe it's not really related what
you're saying right this time but do we
sort of subconsciously come up with
different categories than or find things
easier to categorize than what we should
i mean now we'd all look at each other's
faces but if you have
dreams you can sort of identify somebody
even if they look completely differently
you can say you know and i knew in my
dream this was supposed to be your
father even though he looked like my
math teacher and this thing maybe are we
sort of getting at a different
subconscious sort of essence of people
than when we
in a dream or i don't know i don't know
i know what you're saying people
yeah there must be some other category
or some other way of categorizing yeah i
guess what happens in in a situation a
dream like that is that you have two
conflicting categorizations and one
takes predominance so you say despite
all these exceptions the prototypical
aspects of this
whatever it is are still intact so
you'd have to look at the individual
differences in the dreams to be able to
determine exactly how that happens
but this the prototypical smith brother
this is you know your classic example is
that
how do you identify some family members
is coming from all from the same
families well you have all these smith
brothers there's five of them
and you can all tell they're brothers
but they don't share
the same complete set of characteristics
the prototypical brother maybe has six
characteristics so you might say well a
big nose would be one and a heavy
mustache would be another and a beard
would be a third and big ears would be a
fourth and heavy eyebrows would be a
fifth and glasses say would be a six so
that's your prototypical smith brother
but to be recognizable as a smith
brother perhaps you only have to have
two of these characteristics and the
rest can vary so this character would
have big ears
and the eyes and maybe the mustache but
he'd have a little nose and no beard
and then this character would have the
glasses
and a big nose and the mustache the
little ears
and say a beard anyways you get the idea
and they don't share they're not like
triangles you can't precisely define the
captive characteristics that the smith
smith brothers have theoretically they
all rate to this relate to this central
prototype which we abstract from our
experience in some complex manner
so
the notion of uh
what else is interesting
well the other thing about natural
categories is that instead of being
distinct like
like
proper sexes they can overlap and this
is part of the reason that
well knowing this helps you make sense
of the mythological categories because
they shift with context unfortunately
that makes them difficult to interpret
for example
i one of the most basic divisions of the
world from the mythological perspective
is masculine versus feminine and that's
related in a very
profound way to explore territory versus
unexplored territory
the problem is that whether or not
something is masculine or feminine tends
to
depend on the context of interpretation
so for example if you talk about an
island an ocean then the island is
masculine the ocean is feminine but if
you talk about an island in the sky then
the island is feminine and the sky is
masculine so even though the island is
theoretically objectively the same in
both circumstances it's clock it's
affective classification shifts with
context now you might think well that's
a bizarre property for a categorization
have but the thing is we do this all the
time
this is actually how we derive meaning
in large part it's always context
dependent like most of the words you
know you don't know because someone told
you the meaning of them you know because
you derived the meaning from a context
you see a novel word in one context and
then in another context and then in
another context and you can derive the
meaning from from
from analysis of what's common across
the context
maybe you could define a novel word if
you saw it in 10 different sentences
you'd have enough information there to
figure out what the word means and the
meaning of the word shifts with the
sentence and this meaning of the
sentence shifts with the paragraph and
the meaning of the paragraph shifts with
the essay that's why you can pull things
out of context and reverse their meaning
often so the fact of context dependent
meaning is not that much of a mystery
does everything have effective
significance but i'm a little confused
because
when you see a door or something okay
now someone can say that they see a door
that has you know they it has sensory
you know information like it's a door
you open and close it but they feel
nothing towards it right but does it
have value well it's only it's always
that's what last week for example we
talked about the relationship of things
to your story
right you have your story
and um
like if part of your ideal future so it
doesn't have it doesn't have any
relevance unless it interferes with the
story
not only interferes with if it aids
like you think what look again whatever
it looks to me like
your cortex evolved in part to modulate
the automatic reactions of your limbic
system to stimulate to make you more
flexible it looks to me like what's
happening is that what your cortex has
done is hijacked your olympic system in
this way it says
you can put anything you want into the
goal box
but as soon as you put it there it's a
consumatory reward it doesn't matter
what it is
now you have a lot of underlying
biological systems that have their own
idea about what should be here
but you can still put whatever you want
in there it's a consumatory reward
now as soon as you do that everything
that you encounter is construed in
relationship to that goal so the door is
only relevant if you need to get through
it to get to where you want to go
right now it's not relevant at the end
of the class it will it doesn't have
secrets absolutely
and you shift the significance of things
by shifting your framework of reference
and what we're trying to define is what
constitutes a framework of reference
that's one thing what is a framework of
reference i would say in terms of
natural categories everything within
here
is of one type of thing and everything
outside of it is is of a completely
different type of thing and i try to
define that as the known
and unknown
or you could say as
and i really think this is i've been
trying to chase
say categories have this central
prototype
and there's all sorts of mythological
categories masculine is one category and
feminine is another
sky is a category an earth is a category
matter is a category and water is a
category these things overlap in some
odd way like sky tends to be related to
masculine for example
i've been trying to chase down what's at
the core of these mythological
categories and that's why i come up with
these terms
known unknown and then there's the
process of mediation that's the knower
or you could say and maybe this is even
more fundamental
the unknown is unexplored territory
the known is explored territory
and the knower is the explorer
and that's how we conceive of the world
the world is made of
this this and this
that's it that's how our brain naturally
organizes things
how come um i was a little confused how
come the
heavens or the sky is considered
masculine and hence we would think known
territory
because compared to the earth it seems
like it's more unknown
good question good question
um
i'll have to think about that part of
the answer
that there's two masculine categories
and that's part of the answer is that
explored territory
tends to be
the king
usually the old king michael ciris
for example whereas the noah tends to be
masculine as well that's usually the sun
that's horus
say or marduk
and
these are usually sky gods
they're assimilated to the sun the sun
is assimilated to consciousness so
that's basically the answer to that the
sky is the domain of the sun the sun is
massive why is the sun
well because it's associated with
consciousness illumination enlightenment
it rules during the times when we are
conscious it's also the thing that
fights the dragon of chaos in the night
hacks its way out of the belly of the
beast and then as we're born again in
the morning so that's that's the answer
to
that question i could think of a way
that the sky could be explored territory
relative to the earth for people who
never thought of going up in the sky the
sky is not something you move through
but something that's over you and to
that extent it is explored it's very
predictable and even if you move a great
distance across the earth the sky stays
relatively the same whereas the earth
changes dramatically right yeah that
could be as well it's also the case you
have to remember this is one of the
things that makes analysis of
mythological symbols tricky they do
shift with context and they're not
always culturally stable for the
sumerians the sky was male in the earth
was female but for the egyptians the sky
was female and the earth was male that's
more rare it does happen what seems to
be well so you have to look at you have
to look for the prototype that's at the
core of this to try to make sense of the
shifting relationships so the mother
earth
notion is more common
but the fatherland is is also a
mythological notion right we fight for
the fatherland we fight for the
motherland
those two ideas have slightly different
slants
uh it seems that just to call the
explored the predictable and the
unexplored the unpredictable might be
just as fundamental
yes yes fair enough fair enough
that's a
perfectly reasonable way of looking at
it as well and that's that's basically
where you see the uh neuropsychological
overlap instantly because we do know
now that your emotional systems are are
a priori hardwired to respond to the
unpredictable that's a domain now it
looks to me like
in terms of of neuropsychological
function that the left hemisphere the
linguistic hemisphere it's specialized
for habitual patterns of action
it looks to me like it's the hemisphere
that rules in known territory
you say well your brain is actually
wired up so that it it has one set of
responses that are useful when you know
what the hell you're doing
and then it has a whole other set of
subsystems that are useful when you
don't know what you're doing and when
you do know what you're doing it's the
linguistic left that's
that's you and when you don't know what
you're doing it's the limbically
dominated right hemisphere that
that appears to mediate your actions now
why would i say that well it's partly
because we know the right frontal cortex
responds to punishment and threat
intentionally in front of the a priori
phenomena that appear with the
appearance of the unpredictable so the
right hemisphere is what governs your
behavioral responses when you encounter
something you don't that you can't
predict
in terms of its more cognitive functions
well it governs anxiety that's for sure
it may govern pain that's not so clear
but it looks like it's it looks like
there's a high possibility of it governs
depression anyways
um it's also the part of your brain
that's good at recognizing patterns and
generating stories and my guess is you
can think about this
if you encounter something you don't
understand the first thing you try to do
is to figure out how it's like other
things you've already encountered which
is basically to say that when you're
first trying to adapt to something that
you don't can't predict
you try to apprehend in it familiar
patterns say well even people do this
with the sky you know that's how we get
constellations you have this massive un
undiscovered territory that constitutes
the night sky you chunk it into patterns
and that makes it identifiable and you
have stories that revolve around the
patterns and you start to move the
information from the domain of the
unknown into the domain of familiar
territory and when you think about it
the right hemisphere is the hemisphere
that seems to be specialized for for
stories and for fantasy and it is
fantasy's hypothesis generation as far
as i can tell fantasy is the story of
well maybe it's like this and you're in
your right hemisphere seems to be good
for that so then you have a nice set of
functions it's the thing that
is activated when you encounter
something unpredictable so it stops you
makes you shut up and look
and then the next thing it does is you
start thinking it's specialized for
global pattern recognition recognition
wants to give you a quick and dirty
answer what's out there
well the right hemisphere thinks well
it's like this it's like this it's like
this it's like this and it gives you a
picture so you get something like like
kelly who will encounter it a little bit
later who's uh who's a monster that
inhabits the unknown that's basically
composed of determinate things that are
frightening so like kelly
who's the goddess of the unknown she has
staring face big teeth she sits in fire
she has eight legs like a spider she's a
picture of the thing that lives out
there and the unknown
anyways
okay
can you elaborate more on how the left
hemisphere works
in the uh in the presence of the noun
well it seems to be it seems to be more
specialized for information that you
already know how to handle and it also
it's also good at handling
linguistically mediated information and
by the time you've chalked up the world
into units that you can describe with
words you've already done a pretty good
job of adapting to it you can even
abstractly represent it if you're still
i think
action is a form of categorization
if you really don't know something all
you know about it is that in its
presence you should stop or run that's a
form of categorization it's pretty
generalized information right
by the time you've explored something
really thoroughly you can describe it in
words and you can communicate it and
that seems to be part of what the left
hemisphere does but it's also
responsible you think about it this way
the left frontal hemisphere is also
responsible for the generation of
positive affect now you only generate
positive affect in the presence of cues
of of consumatory reward in the presence
of incentive rewards
now an incentive reward is something
that indicates that you're getting
closer to your goal
okay
now explored territory is basically full
of indications that you're getting
closer to goal that's why it's explored
right because you've already transformed
it from something unknown and
threatening
into something that you can use to get
to where you want to go and the left
hemisphere does that
so it looks to me like well it looks to
me like those things all sort of fit
together
so adaptation basically means and it's
in its most optimal sense adaptation
means that you have transformed
something you do not understand
into something that you can not only
predict but can use
because you just don't want to transform
everything into something irrelevant
right that would be useless you want to
transform things you don't understand
into things that you can do something
with that you want to do
so
so if the individual has a different
balance through which they approach like
the youth like the balance between the
left and right hemisphere or the
approach to the known and the unknown
there's there's some evidence for
variation in temperament
you know some people are more inhibited
and some people are less inhibited now
the problem with that is that
i believe that i mean it does look like
there's pretty solid evidence for these
temperamental variations you might say
that
you have a lower threshold for example
for experiencing anxiety in the presence
of something unknown than the next
person does and that's constant across
situations the problem with that is that
it doesn't take into account the fact
that what's unexpected is always
construed in relationship to historic
my guess is that if people looked into
this they'd find that inhibited people
have different stories about the way the
world is constructed and part of their
biological predisposition towards
timidity
manifests itself in the structure of the
stories they tell themselves about the
world it makes sense because if you're
more
if you're more frightened by people the
stories you tell about them are going to
be twisted more towards the domain of
threat
so do those does that balance also vary
situationally like you said if someone
is refusing to accept anomalous
information that does have relevance for
their story and they're ignoring it
until it gets to a certain point where
they can
yeah i think the whole last half of the
course is about that it's like because
one of the things that you can do to
yourself to make yourself more
pathological is just not adapt to
anomalous information and that makes you
functionally
pathological i think so would that
actually make the right hemisphere less
reactive or would it make it it would
make it would make the left i mean i
don't know is it a compensating function
or is it
i think i think what what happens under
those circumstances is the right
hemisphere starts to make a lot of noise
so your dreams start to
one of the students i had last in in a
class
this class last year has just written a
paper for me on the potential function
of dreams he points out that in in
neural net
in neural net modeling of
pattern recognition
there's a phenomena called catastrophic
failure where if you have a neural net
and it's got a bird category and a fish
category and you throw it a penguin well
what happens is that the bird category
the fish category collapse and all you
get is animal category so there's kinds
of anomalous information that will blow
whole categorization systems so what he
posited was that there's one system that
has that does categorization and another
that slowly feeds into normal
information
so it doesn't collapse so it has time to
adjust its structure to the new
anomalous information without blowing
its whole categorization scheme now you
have to have a categorization scheme
because if you don't you don't know how
to act and if it's really global like if
i tell you you say well how do i write
an essay and i say you act like a human
being i said this is pretty this
information is so vague as to be
completely useless for the task at hand
you want to categorize it you want
information that's
of sufficiently high resolution so that
it laid you in your task if i blow all
your categorization sets and you're just
left with this really amorphous
amorphous categorization you don't know
how to act so you want to maintain your
categories what he suggested was was
that dreams slowly moving all this
information up into the categorization
schemes
so
in terms of your question
well
if you if you constantly ignore
anomalous information pouring in from
the right hemisphere basically what
you've done
is categorize more and more information
into the category of things that are so
terrible they can't be faced and i think
what you do under those circumstances is
you activate a monster so to speak that
lives in your right hemisphere and it
gets more and more and more powerful
until one day when at a weak moment say
it just swallows you whole
and that's when you fall
catastrophically into depression or into
terrible anxiety or maybe even depending
on your physiological predisposition
into something resembling schizophrenia
so you keep because all that information
that you encountered that's anomalous
it's categorized you categorize it by
avoiding it and the category is so
terrible i can't face it so you think
that if you integrate it you don't end
up with nightmares
yes that's right that's right although
if you haven't been integrating it and
you start the nightmares might increase
in intensity and if it's also the case
that when you are dreaming you know your
your uh
your spinal cord your reticular
activating system the part is activating
the hippocampus and the amygdala and
that's the part of the brain that deals
with anomalous information it reverts to
to brainstem control
so it looks to me like this is a good
this is a reasonable hypothesis you have
a system that deals with what you know
and another one it deals with what you
don't know you need both
if you ignore one well there's a whole
social psych literature that says if you
ignore anomalous information you're
happier
you know which is that that's a really
appalling literature because
they don't take temporal duration into
consideration it's real good in the
short term
really
oh there's a hole
yeah that's right that's right the
positive illusion literature is taylor
yeah yeah i mean it's being trashed
with empirical data showing that yeah in
the short term it's a good solution by
the long term you know you get hostile
and anxious and depressed and people
don't like you very much which is you
know hardly all that surprising but they
actually wrote self-help books you know
self-help books telling people that
positive self-illusions were good for
mental health
man despite like 5 000 years of
philosophical evidence to the contrary
both of these hemispheres in the
electron hemisphere working at the same
time when you come across experience
what would happen to a split brain
patient who
has there been any any use well we do
know for example that i don't know
i don't know the literature on emotional
responsivity of split brain patients but
i do know that if you sustain right
frontal cortical damage it makes you
inappropriately non-depressed and
anxious and what that what happens under
those circumstances is that you acquire
functional psychopathy which basically
means that
psychopath doesn't regulate his behavior
as a consequence of information that
indicates that his behavioral output is
doing something that in the long run is
is a bad idea well there's a there's a
famous paper by eslinger and debasio
about a guy who uh can't remember his
initials he had an iq of 143 right
frontal damage
no measurable decrements in iq so he's
still 143 is three standard deviations
above the mean we're talking very bright
person here but he makes a series of
catastrophic decisions that look that
are of the sort that you'd
associate with stupid criminality
he uh gets divorced he marries a uh
well someone who's very bad for him
basically
gets involved in a whole series of
terrible business decisions etc etc so
if you're missing the information from
your right frontal cortex you're happy
no kidding because you've knocked out
the whole system that deals with all
those things that make you unhappy but
you have to be unhappy
to live properly
when you encounter those things that
don't go out according to plan because
if you don't attend to those things that
don't occur according to plan then you
don't learn and if you don't learn you
keep your
model of adaptation stable in the face
of in the face of shifting environmental
contingencies and what that basically
means is that over time
the thing that's you gets old and senile
and that's how it's represented
mythology by the way that's the that's
the image of the wasteland so you know
that's the land where all the trees have
dried up and everything's old nothing
grows and
you can read that as
the absence of the positive aspect of
the great mother
which means that there's no beneficial
novelty around or you can read that as
the tyranny of stupid ideology
either way you're suggesting that are
you suggesting that in the absence of a
connection
the left brain will dominate probably
well one of the things yes i i think
that's true like this is speculative
but there's some there's some
physiological evidence like the left
brain the left hemisphere is dominant in
most circumstances in schizophrenia for
example if you're schizophrenic and you
start hearing voices it appears as
though there's a possibility that the
reason for that is because
the
areas that are associ that are
isomorphic with the language centers but
are in the right hemisphere have been
released from tonic inhibition by the
language centers in the left hemisphere
and are starting to become active and
the way you interpret that is i hear
voices they aren't me
so which would suggest to me that who
you are
as far as you're concerned
is mostly the sum total of
linguistically mediated processes that
localize
usually the left hemisphere but mostly
they're linguistically mediated which is
only to say that mostly what you are as
far as your own self-regard is a
culturally constructed entity
most of which has been constructed using
the mediation of language
so do you think consciousness is resides
in
no no no because first of all there
isn't consciousness there's a bunch of
processes that are consciousness now
like one consciousness that's clearly
conscious is what happens to you when
something anomalous occurs because
you'll orient towards that and i think
orienting is most central to what we
define as consciousness because like
even in this room look
there's only a few things that you're
really conscious of you're very much not
conscious as a general rule of the floor
the ceiling the walls most things around
you the only thing you're conscious of
is that part of your experiential field
where there's some novelty emerging
right that's because your orienting
systems are activated and those are
critical to consciousness and this is
very interesting because
in mythology
in mythology one of the things that
brings about the war
the world
is the capacity to discriminate between
things the capacity to attend to novelty
well i want to get into that in the
course of today's discussion actually
see look
when you're orienting towards things
you're attending to the world that's
defined by chaos
and transforming it with the
intermediation of exploration into
defined territory
from the mythological perspective that's
equivalent to the construction of the
world
now that's why in in christian theology
for example there's the doctrine of the
logos the logos is being assimilated to
consciousness it's a solar like
entity
mediated by
by by language that's why it's the word
it's also assimilated to christ and this
is not a notion that's
unique to christianity as we'll see
that's the thing that creates the world
creates the world by dividing
look here's an example in the earliest
sumerian myths
there's a dragon
who lives in the primordial waters
and he gives rise to
two
wedded deities one's the sky and the
other is the earth
they're separate but not really and the
way the myth represents that is that
they're locked in something technically
called a hairos gamos which is a
mystical marriage so they're in sexual
union they're united they're not really
two things
their union gives rise to a third force
that's their son the god of the
atmosphere as it turns out the sumerian
it's the god of the atmosphere who
separates the pushing the sky up to the
sky and the earth down the earth and
thereby creates the world what the hell
does that mean
well it means that in any creation myth
there's four elements
chaos
and what's chaos
that's the union of everything that will
one at one point be distinct and it's
sometimes represented in mythology
by the union between the mother and the
infant because that's sort of symbiotic
right one's absolutely dependent on the
other but yet in a sense there are two
distinct entities or they will be two
distinct enemies but anyways chaos
that's the dragon
that lives at the bottom of the water it
gives rise to two deities
the earth
and the sky they're locked in sexual
union they give rise to a sun
the god of the atmosphere it's the sun
god
he separates them that's the world now
you could say that the world is born as
a consequence of the interaction of the
sky god and the earth god or you could
say that the world is born as a
consequence of the fact that the sun god
separates the two both stories are
accurate all this story is saying you
have to look at the mythological
representations the stories say well the
earth
this is chaos the earth that's maternal
that's the mother
that's novelty it's the source of all
things
territory
the sun god separates these two things
by discriminating between them which is
basically by
taking the thing that's novel and
transforming it into the thing that's
explored that means the origin of the
cosmos from the mythological perspective
so there's three there's three seminal
elements in the in your standard
creation map
the mother the father and the son the
mother is the unknown unexplored
territory the father's the known
explored territory and the sun is the
process that mediates between them and i
have assimilated that the orienting
reflex because it's the thing that
focuses on in on novelty
initiates the process of exploration
which is the process by which the
determinate world is formed think well
what is the determinate world under
those circumstances well it's
all those places that you can go where
you know how to behave and those places
consist of the territory
but also the behaviors of everyone else
that you interact with so known
territory is social territory
because all of our actions in the
habitual domain are defined by the
actions of others so part of what it is
that we know when we say we know is how
to map the actions and interactions of
others so that's why the known is also
similar to culture
and to the patriarchy
and
to the king
because of course the king
is the behavioral model that defines the
state who everyone in the state imitates
so that everyone in the state can
predict everyone else
that's part of it anyways
so
for me you're exploring territory
because i can define what you're going
to do in this situation and the reason i
can define it's because we share the
same story which is that we're pursuing
goals that are at least
concordant they don't conflict if they
conflicted we'd have trouble
because you'd be mapping things with one
motivational significance and i'd be
mapping them with the other which
basically means we'd either have to
negotiate which means you'd arrange your
story and i'd arrange mine or we fight
that's that's it those are the two
options or i can pretend that the
conflict doesn't exist in which case
sooner or later it will get me
okay now i want to because this is a
course about social identity and social
conflict i want to read you some i'll
get you in one sec i want to read you
some things from mercy at elliott
because it will help you
it will help you understand how it is
that we naturally categorize things so
you want to remember
chaos because that's the thing that
we're
that we're going to discuss now
chaos is what exists before there's a
separation of subject and object and the
thing that chaos is is then both spirit
and matter
terrible mythological way of speaking
i'll give you an example of what that
means
piaget said that the subject constructs
himself as well as the object in the
course of exploration which basically
means that
what you are formed out of
is all those things that you discovered
as you were approaching all those things
you didn't know now you form the world
as a consequence of the
process of exploration but you also form
yourself because it's in the process of
encounter with novelty that you generate
information and it's information that
you build yourself out of so from the
mythological world the thing that's
chaos that existed before the world
existed is composed of spirit
which is what you will be and matter
simultaneously
which is very very that's a very
interesting concept okay question
uh
i i don't want to go off into different
no the the symmetry between the
present goal process
and then the
state one chaos statement
and then the known
nowhere
no unknown nowhere no yeah so that the
knower is in the place of the process
the nor is the process
becomes the mechanism
which embodies the process
yes yes that's right that's right and
that's what religious stories basically
push you towards that's why i wanted to
show you the story of marduk martic is
the person who encounters the unknown
the god who attains the highest position
in the hierarchy of gods who then goes
out to fight timeout who's the dragon of
both she's both the dragon of chaos and
the mother of all things those two
categories get overlapped substantially
and in the in the fight with time out
marduk generates the cosmos
now the mesopotamian king imitates
marduk that's what gives him power
that's that's what gives his position
validity is the fact that he's the
embodiment of the sun god what does that
mean well the sun god is the thing that
makes the world well what does that mean
well the sun god is an image of the
process of consciousness which turns the
unknown which is undefined territory
into explored territory which is the
world and as long as the king so then
the archaic people say
the
state
if the king doesn't do his job the state
becomes sterile crops don't grow for
example and you think what the hell kind
of what how hell kind of attitude is
that if the king doesn't do his job
crops won't grow but what it means is
the king is a pattern of adaptation
if he doesn't constantly update his
behavioral
attributes in the face of shifting
environmental contingencies the
beneficial aspect of the environment
will disappear
so when the archaic people says if the
king doesn't do his job then
the state becomes sin now crops won't
grow they're dead right what do they do
kill the king sacrifice the king or he
has to undergo a ritual
that indicates
sacrifice which actually the king of
mesopotamia did every new years when he
renewed the cosmos he had to do that
because if he didn't renew the cosmos
which basically meant update his pattern
of behavioral adaptation representation
then the environment would drift farther
and farther away from the state and
everything would collapse precipitously
so the king had to
voluntarily encounter novelty or in the
long term he would catastrophically
encounter it along with all his people
anyway
okay um last semester didn't you relate
that somehow to why money has value or
the use of coins oh yeah that's a funny
one all right well a gold coin has the
head of
the head of a head of state on it why
well the gold is a symbol of the sun
and the sun is the sun god an emperor is
put on the point to indicate value
because this is the thing
that is most valuable and it's symbolic
representations of that that we've used
to signify promise basically so
yeah gold has always been assimilated to
the sun at least in the west so
okay now i want to read you some things
from iliadi i think
these things are well from the
perspective of social psychology and the
notion of understanding conflict and the
hopes for its revolut resolution these
sorts of things i think are
revolutionary if you understand their
significance because iliadi basically
describes how it is that people
naturally perceive those who are not
like them now i would say well if i'm
like you
if i'm like you
i share your story
okay
this is a castle we're both inside
i can construe your relationship to me
with regards to our end goal that's
i also will get to this later
this is also a dominance hierarchy
okay the king's at the top of it and
every organization is set up that way
it's like if you and i are both if you
and i and 100 other people are pursuing
the same goal we organize ourselves into
a dominance hierarchy we each have a
position that basically constitutes a
sub-goal of that greater goal and the
utility of the goals are rank ordered in
terms of their importance and the person
who's at the top is simultaneously the
most important person in the dominance
hierarchy and an embodiment of the goal
chief executive officer in the
corporation for example
you could also relate that in thinking
about that this week to
the more complex story remember it looks
like this
and so on
now the thing that's neat about this
is this is also you remember does
everybody remember how this works is
that
the story is actually consists of sub
stories basically all the way down
now the higher you are up on the
dominance hierarchy
the closer you are to the broadest
expanse of this story so if you're just
a functionary in an organization you
have one of these stories and anything
that comes along to disrupt you like if
you get fired is only going to bother
people who are working on that
particular sub goal
now if you're the king
or the chief executive officer you
occupy this territory so like in the
case of a hostile takeover of a
corporation that means the whole
structure is potentially disrupted and
everyone inside that structure feels
anxiety and depression
because their stories are being
disrupted
okay now you can also see how groups
form in relationship to this because
you're
you're most tightly identified with
those who share the most at the most
the broadest subset of your
embedded stories
so
does that make sense would you say that
the response to kennedy's is the nation
right perfect exactly more accurately
the north when the north korean emperor
died people said the sun had set the sun
had set permanently people were on the
street wailing and crying you know
carrying around pictures of the sun god
who disappeared because the whole state
was placed into chaos
right the same thing happens when
when uh when stalin died for example
when any tyrant dies because the tyrant
is well embodied he embodies the story
of the state kill the tyrant
everything collapses people come on the
streets and cry
now
yeah
fry points out that people like queen
elizabeth still draw a crowd because
lots of people still think in a medieval
fashion so to speak but more accurately
queen elizabeth embodies our stories
everyone's story she's the
she's the focal point you could say or
she's the person who incarnates the
abstracted stories now so you could say
that over over top of her objective
reality is
laid
i don't know how you describe it
a glamorous
facade
that people see because of their
subjective interpretations and she acts
out that role
that's right that's projection if you
say that's a good example of projection
they think that what they're so excited
about is the queen
it's her attributes but you can say in a
sense that's true it's what she
signifies for behavior but that's not
exactly
a property of the object now is it now
if you can understand that you get very
close to understanding what it is that
arcade people were referring to when
they were referring to a god
because queen elizabeth in a sense is an
incarnated god
and
the
the more potent gods occupy broader
domains of the story and what the
mesopotamians said
and this is the core for religious
stories in general is that the thing
that should be at the top of the
hierarchy is marduk right mark was
elected by all the other gods to be
the king god he's the process by which
anomaly is transformed into explored
territory and what that basically means
that
if in your hierarchy of values
what's placed above all else
is the necessity of responding to
anomaly every time it manifests itself
then all your
other biological systems that determine
value will operate properly and if you
put something else in the place of that
god so to speak then sooner or later
everything will fall into chaos
that's that
that's what those mythological stories
are trying to tell people that your
attitude towards anomaly that determines
everything
and you have two choices either face it
voluntarily or not and if you don't well
that's why we're reading milton's
paradise lost because milton's paradise
lost is a story about
the consequences of voluntarily
voluntary failure to admit to the
existence of anomaly
okay now
so you see you read my the story of mark
the sumerian myth it's very very
interesting say all those gods
they organize themselves into a
dominance hierarchy so they're
threatened by time match she's the
dragon of chaos she can't she
constitutes unexplored territory she's
going to destroy all the gods
creator gods always do that and that's
because the unknown generates everything
and takes everything back so it has this
ambivalent motivational status the
source of everything and the place that
everything returns to it's a constant
threat it never goes away there's always
something you don't have you don't
expect to deal with
the gods organize themselves into a
hierarchy and they put martic at the top
then he's the king okay
it seems to me that what that story is
telling you with regards to the
construction of the dominance hierarchy
is two things is first of all the
mesopotamian society was the consequence
of the intermingling of a whole set of
cultural groups each of whom had their
own god which is basically their own
representation of the highest ideal
projected more or less into the external
world now there's a lot of differences
between these representations but in the
process of becoming one culture
all these dogs had to fight it out so to
speak for dominance
in the territory defined by
interpersonal communication and the myth
of marduk climbing the dominance here
is the story the cumulative story of the
combat between these gods and the rise
of one god to preeminent status now
you can see
at the end here
um
yeah on page 96 i don't know how many of
you have your book but marduk still have
in in the sumerian myth mesopotamia
martic still has a whole bunch of sort
of other names
that were likely the names of gods who
sooner or later became assimilated to
marduk he sort of took over their domain
and
the mesopotamians said that marduk had i
don't remember how many names 50
and here are some of them and so what
the mesopotamians basically concluded
unconsciously so to speak was that
whatever mardick represented was also
vital to what all these other names
represented and here are some of the
names
he's named
who's the god who restores to life okay
that
is describing his role in the process
that we
have talked about
this
okay
chaos equals death
now
when these mesopotamians say marduk is
the god who restores to life this is
what they mean is this process
this being read as death
stale state yeah rejuvenation the
process that's marduk that's name number
one
who can restore all ruined gods as
though they were his own creation the
lord who by holy incantation restores
the dead gods to life same thing
this is the dead gods
and you could say why is that
all your behavioral patterns of
adaptation are the consequence in the
final analysis of your mimicry of all
those people who came before you and
established mode's
exploration driven modes of adaptation
which is to say that what you consist of
in terms of your behaviors
is the cumulative behaviors of your
whole culture insofar as those are being
adaptively relevant and most of those
were established by people who are now
dead ancestral figures in many religions
the ancestral figures are assimilated to
gods and that's because they determine
your behavior but when anyways
the known is
the domain of the dead gods that's
basically there's an interesting little
sign
this piece of knowledge i know about
that
if you if you're completely identified
with your culture your ideology
means you're the product of people who
live before you not your own original
thought because you've identified a
dogma which defines you it's not you
it's the construction of people who are
dead
ideologically
uh the catchword of an ideology is a
slogan
slogan is derived from the welsh sloig
garb slow egg gear means battle cry of
the dead
which is a nice commentary on ideology
okay um
yes so it seems it okay so the right
hemisphere seems to be what what the the
process is doing what the king is doing
they're the ones that are going out into
the unknown and the ones that are that
are using what they find
something unknown for adaptive behavior
okay hang on what no that's not exactly
right
okay look
chaos that's the dragon so to speak
that's the possibility that's the
unknown before it's been contacted
it's the unknown hypothetically it's the
fact that behind everything that you
know there's this reality that you can't
say anything about
something that you actually encounter
that's unexpected that's the
manifestation of the unknown in your
experience that's an anomaly okay
the right hemisphere is responsible
for
point
in i think in conjunction with the
limbic system is responsible for
pointing out the fact of anomalies just
to say that if you're pursuing your goal
directed linguistically mediated plants
and something you didn't expect occurs
then your
septal hippocampal and the magdelic
systems grab your motor behavior on your
attention and force it towards the
anomaly
then you have then you make a decision
process or ignore
and the thing that makes the decision i
think is the left is left hemispheric
it's the thing that decides whether it
will voluntarily make the descent or
will reject it
so what is it that uses it
because i think we experience chaos
from the affect of perspective
when we're completely dominated by the
processes of the right hemisphere which
is to say the affective aspects of chaos
are basically anxiety
depression
and well i think the third category is
sort of schizophrenic-like synthology
this is right hemisphere mediated we do
not like that
when when your brain has flipped
dominance
from the left hemisphere in the right
hemisphere you feel like dying
in fact you might commit suicide
but so it's that's i mean that's part of
the reason why people are very motivated
not to pay attention to anomaly is this
in its first manifestation it's anxiety
provoking and painful
but you have to balance that against
knowledge that if you don't pay
attention to it all that will happen is
that it will grow until
instead of you facing it it will attack
you likely when you're weak
okay so so you have this anomalous piece
of information the right hemisphere
focuses on it the left hemisphere says
go after it or not or ignore it and then
does it then call again to the right
hemisphere to
to use patterns to identify it etc and
then well okay that's that's a good
question because the thing about an
anomalous experience is it doesn't
present itself purely in in its
objective manifestation let me give you
an example so you're sitting in your
apartment at night it's quiet
and you hear a noise that shouldn't be
in another room
okay so you're reading that disrupts
your reading let's say you hear
something fall over something big
that disrupts your reading it's like
your goal directed activity is being
eliminated it's like you're alert you
wait you might even wake up if you're
asleep but you're alert so you walk
cautiously or you might run out of the
house that's one way of dealing with it
or you might phone the police but let's
say you decide to explore well you're
conflicted
because you're driven towards it but
you're also
anxious so you
walk towards the room and let's say the
door is slightly more like this
and it's dark in there
and you reach your hand in
to turn on the light you watch what your
mind does when you do that
say if you watch the pictures that it
generates because it's trying to figure
out what the hell is in there you'll get
well all sorts of fantasies about the
potential thing that might be in the
next room now if you actually watch
yourself do this you generate well some
of the in some of the visions will be
more or less realistic
capitalism maybe it's american but you
also get images that are monstrous like
that's what's well that's both a
hypothesis
that your brain is generating about what
might have done it a warning that
something terrible might be in that room
because you know like you really do not
want to put your hand in there
and the anomaly all at once because it
already it emerges the anomaly emerges
in a sense in already categorized form
that's the thing you never really
encounter chaos per se
as soon as something unexpected happens
it's already presenting itself in the
form of a potential hypothesis
so i think your right hemisphere is
doing the pattern recognition instantly
so then it seems like the left
hemisphere is the decision maker
basically it just uses the right
hemisphere for for okay what is what is
anomalous what give me the patterns and
then let's let's see how to use this for
adaptive for my adaptive behavior to get
to that i think that i think that's i
think that's how it works i think the
information if there's a continuum
between entirely explored and not
explored at all as information moves
from the category of not explored at all
to entirely explored it moves across the
hemisphere so to speak so this the
locale of specialization shifts and
there's evidence for this i mean the
right hemisphere does seem to be the
place where activity takes place most
particularly when you don't know what
the hell you're doing
also the other thing that happens is
that like if you're practicing a new
activity when you first start practicing
huge areas of the cortex light up and as
you get good at it
the area that's involved gets smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller till
there's just a tiny center somewhere
that's really specialized for that
activity and then it's not conscious
anymore you do it automatically like
typing everything together
well
i don't know that i
i don't know enough about the literature
on specialization to tell you but for i
don't know where motor patterns end up
localizing for example i don't think
anybody knows we know that the
prefrontal cortex is involved in
construction and monitoring of motor
plants when they're first being
formulated but once they're perfected
where they go it seems still somewhat
mysterious the um
yeah it seems involved in my in like
regulating the smoothness of their of
their uh
of their
application but and the basal ganglia
are involved in motor output too but
where those patterns are localized i
don't think anybody knows yet
it seems a bit rash to generalize the
two hemispheres as these are absolutely
separate absolutely
patterns of activity yes it is rash and
the thing is is that broadly this is
broadly speaking and i don't think it's
so much a matter of hemispheric
specialization maybe as whether the
information is linguistically mediated
or still in image form or whether it's
an image form or still at the level of
behavior so
you know
it's you risk simplification to think of
it in terms of hemispheric
specialization but there's still there's
still enough useful information to be
derived that way to make it to make it
worthwhile so if you were to look at
language then could you say that that
the organization of thoughts and all
that is left hemisphere but but style
and and the actual thoughts come from
the right hemisphere
it doesn't seem right just
broadly speaking again i would say that
there's some evidence for that things
like style that is pattern recognition
capacity i mean that's
that's all like
the font on a given typeface for example
has nothing to do with the information
per se it's sort of an emergent property
or styles and architecture literature
and so on there are patterns that are
difficult to and i think they are
related to
to story and image so
i know you know the right hemisphere is
specialized for the comprehension of
stories it is specialized for the
comprehension of patterns it's the
hemisphere that's responsible for your
understanding of music and most
non-verbal cues it broadly specialized
for negative affect so
and it's also archetectonically
constructed so that it has a left less
differentiated structure than the left
hemisphere which seems to indicate
it's better for quick and dirty analysis
and i think what it does is use metaphor
it says this unknown thing
has the same attributes as all these
other unexpected things that you've
already encountered so look out
so
which is useful information if you don't
know anything else about the unknown
it's good to know that it's like all
those other things that you already
encountered that you didn't understand
but i think what's happened with in
religious systems in large part is that
people have constructed images of the
unknown
by kelly
and then used those as ritual models
against which to practice patterns of
adaptation that are specialized not for
anything particular but for adaptation
to the unknown in general because that's
really what you have to know not how to
do something but how to do something
when you don't know how to do anything
that's really what you need to know so
you get things like
the great goddess who's responsible for
death
the only thing to her that's acceptable
is a human sacrifice what does that mean
well they're richly acting out this
says
to get from here to here to make an
adjustment to the fact of chaos requires
constant sacrifice what a sacrifice of
the king for example but the king is a
pattern of adaptive behavior before you
can understand that
in the image or semantically you act it
out and that's where those rituals come
from so that placates the goddess
endless sacrifice well that's right
but what is it well it's endless
sacrifice of that thing that you value
most which is in fact in the abstracted
form your current set of beliefs and
your configuration your view of the
world the thing you want to give up the
least because it's the thing that
protects you from emotional chaos that's
what you have to sacrifice all the time
in order to adapt to the fact of the
unknown
okay
back to social psychology
i want to read you these things from
iliada
this is very interesting
for religious man space is not
homogenous
he experiences interruptions and breaks
in it
some parts of space are qualitatively
different from others
draw not nigh hither says the lord to
moses put off thy shoes from off thy
feet for the place where i'm now
standing is holy ground
exodus 3 5
there is then a sacred space
and hence a strong significant space
there are other spaces that are not
sacred and so are without consistency or
or structure they are amorphous have no
definition
nor is this all for religious men this
spatial non-homogeneity finds expression
the experience of an opposition between
space that is sacred the only real and
really existing space and all other
space
the formless expanse that surrounds it
okay
it must be said at once that the
religious experience of the
non-homogeneity of space is a primordial
experience he means by that an
archetypal experience doesn't have to be
learned it's a structural element of
experience
homologous to the founding of the world
it is not a matter of theoretical
speculation but of a primary religious
experience that precedes all reflection
the on the world
for it is the break affected in space
that allows the world to be constituted
because it reveals a fixed point the
central axis for all future orientation
when the sacred manifests itself
there is not only a break in the
homogenative space there is also
revelation of an absolute reality
opposed to the non-reality of the vast
surrounding expanse the manifestation of
the sacred ontologically founds the
world okay now what iliadi is trying to
say there is that look your cognitive
systems are founded upon certain
presuppositions
and what eliadea is trying to do and
this is what guillain was trying to do
too with his identification of the
archetypes is to point out what are the
most fundamental levels of
presuppositions upon which all the
things that you think in fact are based
as uh kurt godel pointed out that any
any internally
any internal and consistent system
logical system is necessarily predicated
on presumptions that can't be proved
from within the system they have to be
accepted they're axioms like the axioms
of geometry this is an axiom there's
defined territory and undefined
territory this is what you protect this
is where you live it's the establishment
of this
that is the precondition for everything
else you do so establishing that initial
sacred space that's a religious act the
primary religious act
so what is clear so it's clear to what a
degree the discovery that is the
revelation of sacred space possesses
existential value for religious man for
nothing can begin
nothing can be done without a previous
orientation and any orientation implies
acquiring a fixed point
it is for this reason that religious man
has always sought to fix his abode at
the center of the world that's where the
medieval notion that man existed or that
the earth was the center of the cosmos
that's where that idea came from it
wasn't an empirical notion it was the
notion that wherever we live that's the
center that's defined space surrounded
necessarily by an expansive territory
that we haven't explored now we already
know too
what to make of that in terms of
implications because we know what
unexplored territory signifies first it
signifies fear
then it signifies promise so defined
territory is security
established in an expanse of anxiety and
and curiosity
but aid priority it's anxiety so your
village is surrounded by the places you
don't go because it's frightening out
there why is it frightening no
behavioral structures have been erected
to make that space habitable so it's the
domain of
monsters it's the domain of wolves it's
the domain of foreigners it's the domain
of barbarians it's the place that you
can't explore it's like the old maps the
old medieval maps of the world defined
territory amorphous edges surrounded by
ocean with monsters that's what that
means
there are monsters out there in unknown
territory that's it's interesting too
because the monsters always take the
form of whales but whales aren't whales
for medieval people because they didn't
know what whales were there are serpents
sea serpents that live in the sea and if
you go out there out beyond explored
territory the sea serpent comes out of
the sea and swallows you that's the
hero's mission right down into the belly
of the beast you might come back and you
might not but what that is is the
projection of mythology onto the world
so for the european the age of
exploration was an extraordinary radical
event absolutely absolutely yeah
yes yeah
well here i'm going to tell you exactly
exactly how radical it was this is
something iliadi is that pains to
describe one of the outstanding
characteristics of traditional societies
is the opposition that they assume
between their inhabited territory and
the indeterminate space that surrounds
it the former is the world
more precisely
our world
the cosmos so when marta constructs the
cosmos that's what that means he's
constructing habitable territory the
definable world out of the amorphous
reality that surrounds it
out everything outside the cosmos is no
longer cosmos but a sort of other world
a foreign chaotic place people by ghosts
demons
foreigners
who are assimilated to demons and to the
souls of the dead
now this is this is some other research
that i did so this is
an insert
more specifically to the dragon of chaos
okay so this is the point here
your natural category of foreigner
is the dragon of chaos they're in the
same category not because you've
assimilated them together but because
you have not yet distinguished them
they're still the same thing so your
natural response to the foreigner is
he's the
thing that isn't human that occupies the
space defined by chaos who's a prior
motivational significance is the
generation of terror and disorder so say
you don't need an explanation then about
why people are hostile to foreigners
what you need is an explanation for
those few instances where that does not
in fact occur
okay in
okay
among the hicks sauce
barbarians were assimilated to apophis
who devours the sun
no sorry
yeah that's right the hixos were
barbarians from the egyptian point of
view they kept coming into egypt and
disrupting everything they were
assimilating hicks meant barbarians
and they were assimilated to apophis who
devours the sun okay so that's the
egyptians among the indo-europeans the
ancestors of the modern indians the
assimilation of enemies in battle
to the slaying of virta
in fact enemies were called vertons and
virta was the gigantic dragon who held
back the waters in the hollow of the
mountain
indra slayed him and constructed the
world so for the indo-europeans the
slaying of enemies was precisely
equivalent to the act that constructed
the world and that is because when you
slay your enemies you expand your
territory and the expansion of territory
is equivalent construction of the world
it's a heroic enterprise you're battling
the enemies of the state
among the zoroastrians in iran he who
triumphs into battle he truly kills uh
sorry the fight of the hero pray tonight
against the dragon as he de hakka
is recounted as the struggle of king
ferdinand against a foreign usurper the
dragon asda hack again it's the same
story this is an iranian story
foreigners are the dragon of chaos they
bring disorder into the state so to
overthrow the foreigner to establish new
territories to do the same thing that
the deity did when he established the
world
now
okay
at first this cleavage at first sight
this cleavage in space appears to be due
to the opposition between an inhabited
and organized hence cosmicized territory
and the unknown space that extends
beyond its frontiers on one side there's
a cosmos on the other side of chaos
but we shall see that if every inhabited
territory is a cosmos this is precisely
because it was first consecrated because
in one way or another it is the work of
the god
gods or is in communication with the
world of the gods who determine destiny
in that territory and who therefore
constitute the organizing principles of
the society the dominance hierarchy that
rules there
that's the thing you know inside sacred
space you're all you're pursuing a goal
that's shared by everyone else that's in
that space so their behavior is all
rendered predictable as a consequence of
their participation in the same story
it's a religious story that's defined by
the dominance of a certain god so when
you go out into new territory the first
thing you do is consecrate that new
territory to the god that rules your
territory so the order rules order
reigns there that means the world's
created and what it means that order
reigns there is that whenever other
people go there they have to behave the
same way you behave so they're
predictable so that means they're out of
the domain that's defined by chaos and
they don't terrify you they don't
undermine
they don't pose the possibility of
undermining everything that it is that
you believe in so eliades says
all this appears very clearly from the
vedic ritual for taking possession of
the territory
possession becomes legally valid through
the erection of a fire altar consecrated
to acne
this is a quote from the religious text
the shadow path of ramana
one says that one is installed when one
has built a fire altar and all those who
build the fire altar are legally
established okay so this is rules for
encountering new territory
by the erection of a fire altar agni is
made present
you see a direction of a fire altar
that's a symbol of the construction of
civilization
because the mastery of fire is something
that's absolutely integral to the
establishment of order
anyways
but the meaning of the ritual is far
more complex and if we consider all of
its ramifications we shall understand
why concentrating a territory is
equivalent to making it a cosmos for in
fact the erection of an ulcer to agony
is nothing but the reproduction on the
microcosmic scale of the creation the
water in which the clays makes the clay
for the altar is assimilated to the
primordial water chaos
the clay that forms the base of the
altar symbolizes the earth the lateral
walls represent the atmosphere and so on
and the building of the altar is
accompanied by songs that proclaim which
cosmic region has just been created
hence the erection of a fire altar which
alone validates taking possession of a
new territory is equivalent to the
construction of the world
an unknown foreign and unoccupied
territory which usually means unoccupied
by our people still shares in the fluid
and larval modality of chaos
by occupying it and above all by
settling it man symbolically transform
it transforms it into a cosmos through a
ritual repetition of the creation of the
world what is to become our world must
first be created and every creation has
a paradigmatic model the creation of the
universe by the gods
when the scandinavian colonists took
possession of iceland and cleared it
they regarded the enterprise neither as
an original undertaking nor as human and
profane work for them the labor was the
repetition of a primordial act a
transformation of chaos into cosmos by
the divine act of creation
when they tilled the deserted soil they
were in fact repeating the act of the
gods who organized chaos by giving it a
structure forms and norms
whether it is a case of clearing
uncultivated ground or of conquering and
occupying a territory already inhabited
by other human beings ritual taken
possession must always repeat the
cosmogony from the view of archaic
societies everything that is not our
world is not yet the world
the territory can only be made ours by
creating an anew
this religious behavior in respect to
unknown lands continued even in the west
down to the dawn of modern times
the spanish and portuguese conquistadors
discovering and conquering territories
took possession of them in the name of
jesus christ the raising of the cross
was equivalent to consecrating the
country hence in some way to a new birth
for through christ old things are passed
away behold all things become new 2
corinthians 5 17. the newly discovered
country was renewed recreated by the
cross of course when the americans
landed on the moon the first thing they
did was put up the american flag that's
not but that's the
it's a profane
repetition of precisely the same notions
this is this undiscovered territory is
now part of the world
order rules there are not chaos
so
also it's explored through the ritual
after that because like in that what was
it from the cytoplasm
um
agonized like the fire gods that's of
the god of transformation so if you're
transforming that land from that which
is on a sport to that which is explored
and thereby
making it simultaneously sacred part of
that sacred territory yep okay yeah
that's right that's exactly right and
the ritual that you undergo when you're
creating the fire temple is equivalent
to participating in the act for example
it's defined by marduk which is the the
fighting with the dragon that's
represent see i read i think the reef
this you might think this is completely
off the wall but i've thought about for
a long time it makes a certain amount of
sense to me chaos is represented by a
dragon why why a dragon there aren't any
dragons i mean it's partly because a
dragon is a creature of matter because
it's a serpent and it goes around on the
ground and has wings so it's also a
creature of the air so it's a symbol of
the union of opposites it's also a
serpent so it can shed its skin and be
reborn so there's an element of
transformation in there but i saw this
great picture it's a picture from the
medieval church it's called souls in the
grip of hell and there's there's a
picture of this uh monstrous dragon and
inside it's wood it's a carving inside
it there's all these people who have
horrified expressions on their face but
they've been devoured by a serpent now
we share
our ascending spinal tracts on our
limbic system with animals going a long
ways back on the phylogenetic chain and
our limbic system the hippocampus is
dissolved as amphibians in fact the
hippocampus first made its appearance
when our ancestors crawled out of the
water which is kind of kind of
interesting from a symbolic perspective
i think the reason that the dragon of
chaos is symbolized by a dragon is
because when we fall into that our
actions and affects are dominated by
parts of our brain that are so old that
they still partake in the aspect of the
world that's defined by by reptilian
potency
anyways
you can think about that i mean i've
debated whether or not to
to make a point of that in this
manuscript because it seems to be kind
of a strange notion but the fact is
there are dragons everywhere in the
world and they're representative of
something
okay so we think in these ways and draw
these distinctions naturally it's not a
feature of the object so we would tend
to think well it depends on how you
define the object
i mean we would tend to think in these
ways even when the territory that we're
exploring isn't a spatial object even if
it's something abstract like a concept
absolutely look our ideological concepts
or especially ideological concepts are
actually abstract representations of
adaptive behavioral patterns they're not
descriptions of the objective world like
if you share marxist ideology marxist
ideology is a body of laws which
basically means that it's a verbal
representation of a pattern of action
that's designed to transform order into
chaos chaos and order although with the
marxists it works the other way around
so that's right your ideological
identification is in fact your abs your
identification with uh with a god of
behavior that's become abstracted into a
higher order philosophy okay but don't
you think that that i mean obviously in
those situations then you can use that
as an impetus to fight or to have war
but i think that in some cases the fact
that it's not a spatial object or a
literal possession or territory or land
might change the way that we approach it
i mean we'd still approach it in the
same way in our minds but the
consequences no i think it's worse i
think it's worse because look if once
if you take an animal and you train it
so that it so that it's adapted to a
territory you can't come along and have
an argument with it and thereby
undermine its whole sequence of
adaptations like once the animal's got
its adaptation fixed about the only
thing you can do to really follow it up
is to shift its environment like you can
move it somewhere else
but if you have abstracted your pattern
of adaptation up into an ideology that's
verbally mediated and i come along with
a set of principles that that make
logical nonsense of some of your
presuppositions i can blow apart whole
schemes of your adaptation in the course
of say an afternoon and it might take a
long time for the consequences of that
to like
have their effect on all your structures
of adaptation but the point is is that
once i transform my adaptations into
words i can adapt abstractly and that's
really useful right i mean i can build
potential adaptive models in the
abstract without having to hack them out
that's the positive side but the
negative side is once i can abstract up
the principles i'm really vulnerable to
an argument and what an argument is is a
war that's fought with the words and if
it fails then we just cascade down the
chain of abstraction to the actual
conflict
so i'm not really asking about ideology
so i guess what i'm trying to get out of
something more like
if they're like if there is a fertile
valley 10 miles outside of my order and
you're there i have to if i'm not going
to cooperate with you i have to kill you
in order for me to have that in order
for me to explore it for it to be mine
but if i'm studying astrophysics and
you're an astrophysicist in china i
don't necessarily have to kill you in
order for me to be able to study even
the exact same thing that you're
studying
i mean would you symbolically kill this
person by
by firing off letters under mine
yeah look that's that's now that's a
good that's a good example because
there's no necessary reason why a
scientific model has to simultaneously
take on the affect of valence of an
adaptational model
but to the degree that your career is
contaminated with your ideas you're
going to respond to your competitors as
if they were enemies so if you've
abstracted yourself from your objective
ideas which basically means if you have
a life that's independent of your
scientific beliefs then you can treat
them as objective elements and there's
no necessary reason for you to get your
emotions involved but the truth like the
real situation tends not to be that way
people get their
objective pictures tangled up with their
religious beliefs and then they do view
attacks on their domain as personal
attacks now you're not supposed to do
that in science in fact
science is actually the mechanism
whereby we separate those two types of
models but it doesn't always work
so so it seems like
if you're like
like when you're literally exploring the
actual physical world it's
absolutely inevitable that there's going
to be physical violence and conflict and
there's no even possibility of getting
around that i mean in principle that is
a necessary part of it but then
so is it wrong to say then that when
you're no longer studying the
physical world when you're studying more
abstract things that most likely you're
probably still going to behave the same
way but there's at least the possibility
that you can no i wouldn't say okay no i
wouldn't say that like i don't think
if you're studying things that are
objective you have in principle the
possibility of being objective about
them but you have to fight over it if
there's one thing and we both want it we
won't cooperate we must share it
i mean like about right two people
right right there are like your first
premise was that the bloodshed was a
necessary intermediary okay but that's
not one of the things we want to do in
this course
the reason that i'm interested in the
structure of myths to begin with is to
figure out look here's your alternatives
if i let your ideas into my head
then i end up
in chaos
that's one option
okay so i don't let your ideas into my
head by killing you that's another
option now both of those options seem to
me to be pretty pretty distressing you
can't expect me to give up everything i
believe in just because you have a
different idea by the same token if the
only way that we can settle our disputes
is through force and you have an
antibody i have one well that's pretty
much the end of the story there too so
it's sort of
anxiety depression and the possibility
of suicide and cultural degeneration on
one side or
like conflict that will kill us both on
the other side right those are you might
describe those as the horns of a dilemma
but then the question is well given that
dilemma what's the is there an
alternative path well that's what we're
hopefully going to define mostly in the
second part of the course
because that's the dilemma it's a
terrible dilemma i mean before
if you had axes stone axes and sticks
and so did i and we had a fight well
there was at least the possibility that
one of our groups wasn't going to end up
yet
but now when we're talking about
territorial disputes between powers that
are
fully armed the possibility for
settling the problem violently doesn't
even exist
unless you're willing to unless you'd be
willing to kill me
unless you'd be willing to die just to
kill me which of course is always a
possibility
depends now like how deep your desire
for revenge actually is
so the middle road is always compromised
right i mean because you copper if you
have an argument with someone you maybe
you take a little of their idea
and they think enough of yours so that
you can so that you can get along well
and if you have a if you have a more
sort of physical situation
you you just compromise in terms of
getting what you want isn't that isn't
that exactly what what culture is is
compromise so that everyone well
certainly at least in part compromise
because if you and i are modifying our
behavior in some territory part of its
dispute but part of it's well if you do
this i'll reward you and if i do that
this you'll reward me and so like it's
positive mutual modification but also
it's i can't have everything i could
possibly want i mean if i could just
have everything i could possibly want i
would not function and i could not
function in society at all right right
you get well what you do is essentially
theoretically is you give up some
immediate gratification for the long
term
possibility of continued
stable gratification i mean that's one
way of looking at it or at least for
being able to live in society which you
have to do right exactly because that's
the social contract sort of notion right
now so but you said compromise and i
would say well rather so if you know
here's your negative option one which is
i kill you and here's negative option
two which is i listen to you and thereby
lose all my faith well then the question
is like is there some mediating
principle
that isn't either of these that can be
used instead of them and i would say
well that's why we're studying what
marduk represents because i would say at
the core of all belief systems
is a representation of the process by
which the belief system was erected
which is the most important thing about
the belief system so if you're if you
have belief system a that you're like
dogmatically attached to and i believe
system b and i'm dogmatically attached
to it and i point out to you that
despite our differences at the core the
most important thing is something that
we actually both agree about that might
help in some way smooth the possibility
of transition it would also make us at
least reasonable negotiators because
well here's an example
you have to see if i want to negotiate
with you we need a higher order point of
reference
that defines the rules because otherwise
i might make an agreement with you and
then just like cut you into shreds the
first chance i get right so you have to
be able to trust me
even to begin the process of negotiation
so i would say well this is a weird
example but let's say in in the
christian marriage ceremony you might
think of that as the union of two uh
disparate territories well the notion is
is that the male and the female are
supposed to subordinate themselves to
the process that christ represents
that's marduk
and
horus
etc and indra
and buddha
and why is that well it's because this
person has you know their story
and this person has their story
and
the union of the stores produces a lot
of unknown territory like right away and
in order to mediate between the two you
need a higher order principle which says
so that's the rules it's like okay i'll
negotiate with you but you have to trust
me and vice versa we have to put the
possibility of trust above all our
disputes so you say well trust is one of
the aspects here
etc cetera so then we have a higher
order point of reference to mediate our
dispute so i'm saying well if this is
one territory this is another we need to
find out what rules the unexplored
spaces in between so that when we get
there we know how to act
the type of thing that you want to
explore isn't the type of thing that
inherently
precludes like
there are some types of things that if i
want to have it i must keep everyone
else from having it in order that i can
have it yeah that's the zero-sum game
right and there are other sorts of
things that aren't that way like for
instance if
if i just had this
dispute that i couldn't resolve with the
chinese astrophysicist i would not
necessarily need to even acknowledge
that he was studying something i mean i
i don't know well that's true okay look
look there are gonna be like i wouldn't
have to fight again i would not have no
idea
this is your story and this is his story
you both established domains of reality
cosm cosmos
i don't know what the plural of that is
to cause
by definition
as long as he's studying phenomena that
are irrelevant to your pursuits but even
if he's studying the exact same thing i
do not have to keep him from studying it
just so that i can study it so i do not
have to kill him as long as you as long
as the implications of what he discovers
have no negative significance for your
ongoing story that's that's that's yeah
that's important well it seems like when
you're like limited just solely to the
physical world like landscapes and
rivers and who's going to own the valley
then if you're not going to cooperate
and you're not going to give up your
goal you have to kill them but if it's
an abstracted thing like you're not
studying a particular tree or a
particular ant but you're just studying
a concept there's enough unexplored
territory for everyone yeah and even if
he wants to study the exact same bit of
territory
economists make that argument about
limited territory too all the time as
they say because there are some
economists who basically follow uh
what's the population theorists who said
we were all destined to starve
malthus yeah there's some economists who
take a malthusian perspective which is
that everything's a zero-sum game and so
the competition for resources is
necessary and there's others who say
well no that's not true because
you you redefine territory by
transforming your adaptive structure and
that means that what may look like
bounded territory is only bounded
because of the way that you approach it
and if you think of a new way to
approach it well then there's plenty of
resources for all and so far the
non-malthusians i think are winning the
argument which is to say that
territories defined by your behavior in
it not by any objective aspects of the
territory so yeah isn't there a
distinction between struggle over goods
and really
these are really structures of belief
i mean it seems like you can
i would say i would say not not usually
because
what constitutes a good is always
construed in relationship to the pursuit
of a goal like we fight wars over oil in
the 20th century but we wouldn't fight
wars over oil in the 19th century
because the affect of the affect of
valence of petroleum has shifted as a
consequence of a shift in our
environmental structure so and that's a
natural good so to speak but like i
don't buy the concept of natural
resource i think i think there's a real
flaw in logic somewhere there because
natural resource plays the same role in
economic theory as stimuli does in
psychology yeah i mean something
different
we agree that oil isn't good and so
we're fighting okay yeah that's one
thing then to say that i look at the
world in such a way that
i went to the world very difficult i
look at the world in such a way that
your way of looking at the world is
inherently a threat to it because it's
different from my from mine
and so it's not exactly that we can
compromise
we have to come up with some integrative
principles right absolutely that that's
why i was taking disputing
over oil it seems to me
yes i would say yes because we can't in
other words
we have to
get to some other
level so to speak yes we should do that
with the fight over oil too because
there should be a higher theoretically
at least there might be a higher order
set of principles to which we would be
willing to subordinate our competition
for oil yeah i mean and it seems i don't
think it's it's not
i don't think it's unreasonably utopian
to presume that in the long run it would
be better if we could get as much as
possible for everyone it would be like
from the selfish perspective better like
i think it was a historically anomalous
event for example that the americans
rebuilt japan instead of burning it to
the ground and plowing it under with
salt which is your more standard human
response to a to a demolished enemy and
the same might be said about germany but
the addition of japan to the world
economic power strikes me as a net
benefit even to the victors because
there was a great evil which was uh
union well that plus the japanese are
online so to speak we have access to the
creative intelligence of an additional
several hundred million people or
however many people inhabit japan
so that's it's not a zero-sum game
there's no necessary reason to construe
it as a zero-sum game it can be played
that way
but it's i think it's an error
so that eliminates the no the notion of
the distinction between like limited
resources and ideas because resources
are
look at i mean i ideas at ideas and i
see this danger that you know you can
get ideologies and fight words over them
but on the other hand to me they seem it
seems to present a more optimistic
playing field because
just if we have this drive to explore
that must be
satisfied and want we want to explore
the physical environment
we must fight we must either cooperate
or fight because if there's one object
and that there aren't duplicate copies
of it and only one person can explore it
i must fight yeah i see what you can do
we
i always kind of thought that the space
race was good for that for precisely
that reason it's a great it's a great uh
outlet for necessary exploratory
tendencies that would not necessarily i
mean yeah haven't you haven't you uh
been saying all along at the whole point
of abstraction sort of in terms of
evolutionary development is so that you
can figure out what's good and bad
without actually going out there and
getting slaughtered right what's bad
right so that therefore and our whole
cultural system is being extracted so
that you can have you can do these
things
but it has a very hi the problem with it
is that it has this attendant danger
that we haven't discussed which is the
tan cascade right yes you can also blow
your whole system it's like that's i
think that's what we did with the
science i guess i should i know it's not
quite three
when the scientific revolution came
about the discoveries of the scientific
revolution in abstract form seemed to
contradict the presumptions of the
religious systems upon which we erected
our adaptational structures so the
consequence of abstraction was that we
could destroy our belief systems and
that brought on an existential crisis so
the problem with abstraction is yes you
can explore the abstract it's very
powerful but you can also be undermined
really easily by words so another reason
that it's really useful to study
mythology i think is because it gives
your ideology your necessary belief the
kind of firm ground that can no longer
be undermined easily by a few casual
words because you're not
like
you're no longer if you think about it
as a tree
if you're way up here in the branches
you haven't got the foggiest clue what's
down here it's all unconscious so to
speak which is to say it's all
procedural or it's still embedded in
images somebody can come along and give
you a bit of harassment here and it
blows your whole
adaptational structure apart you hate
that i mean it's very hard on you but
that's mostly because
you don't know what's down here so your
house is built on shifting sand and not
on a rock and the point is you're
supposed to specify him with the
philosopher's stone inventory that we'll
get to in the second half of course but
the idea is that you're supposed to
build your house on a rock and the point
is you have to figure out what that rock
is
that's that's part of the reason why
we're spending so much time discussing
this pattern of adaptation because if
you know that in your belief system is a
description of the process by which
belief systems are generated and that's
the thing that you need to know above
all else well it makes you much more
resistant to the casual disruption of
your of your adaptation structure is you
know what you should do when you don't
know what to do which is the thing you
need to know the most
so
yeah um just for the reading
is it are we supposed to read all the
entire texts
in the active theater oh that's a good
question
the simple answer would be yes
let me see while you use the abuse of
history it's pretty short the basic
writings of nietzsche no you don't have
to read all that read beyond good and
evil as much of it as you can it's very
difficult to read but
but it's very useful the great mother
well
look the reason i assign the great
mother is because that's the most
comprehensive survey i know of the
symbolism of novelty basically of the
great mother and what i what you should
do is go through it and get familiar
with what it is that newman's saying
basically all he's doing is saying well
there's a sim he thinks it's the
collective unconscious by the way
which is right in a sense
there's a domain that's the unknown it
has a positive side and negative side
here's the symbols that have accumulated
around that domain
in representation if you read that like
go through it enough so that you get a
feel for the language of the symbols
which basically means you have to
understand when you see a statue of
diana who has a multitude of breasts you
have to understand what that image
signifies and when you see kelly who has
who's eating someone she's giving birth
to you have to be able to see it known
as a foreign artifact but as a
representation of something that you
understand so you have to read that book
enough until you get the language
the reason for that is because unless
you can unless you understand those
mythological representations
you have no idea how terrifying the
thing is that you want to avoid
because in normal circumstances
in our well-protected existences we
never ever encounter anything that
scares us badly enough to let us know
how scared we could be
if you look at these mythological
representations you can get an abstract
notion of how terrifying unexplored
territory really is and it's very useful
gives
instant insight into other into the
artistic productions of archaic cultures
so
and uh
the origins and history of consciousness
well
that's basically the best book that i
know of that describes hero mythology so
again you have to go through these
enough so that you get the gist of what
the authors are trying to
are trying to describe like
in the great mother newman describes the
symbolism of novelty in the origins and
history of consciousness he describes
the symbolism of the process that
explores novelty so again you want to
get a picture of it because then you'll
start understanding references to heroes
and and so on as we as we proceed
through that
through the course
no not really not really um
not really